hola buenas tardes pues hace escasos
minutos la cámara de diputados se
aprobaba con 101 votos a favor 30 en
contra y 2 abstenciones el penúltimo
paso de lo que puede ser el la ley del
proyecto de matrimonio igualitario en
chiles espera ahora que este proyecto
sea visto por el senado donde partió la
iniciativa y donde ya fue aprobado de
manera positiva y también de forma
contundente así que este sería el
penúltimo paso después de que el
presidente sebastián piñera en su última
cuenta pública y tomando a todo el mundo
por sorpresa incluso a muchas personas
de su sector que son contrarias a el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
le pusiera el carácter de urgencia
esperamos pues que pronto en las
próximas semanas este proyecto pueda
concretarse bueno patricia y sobre la
despenalización del aborto seguimos a la
espera se sabe algo de la hora de
votación como ambos temas e incluyendo
el del matrimonio igualitario y la
adopción igualitaria son influyentes en
la segunda vuelta electoral que va a
enfrentar al ultraderechista cast y el
irs izquierdista a favor y que tras una
primera contienda este domingo que pasó
bueno veremos a ver lo que ocurre está
en
que está en agenda que las próximas
horas se debata sobre el tema del aborto
que es una ley eso sí mucho más
incipiente que necesita de ser aprobada
en el caso de que salir adelante muchos
más pasos todavía y que donde la
discusión valórica será todavía mucho
más fuerte es un tema muy sensible en el
país y como tú bien mencionas está en
las campañas electorales de ambos
candidatos uno a favor y otro totalmente
en contra incluso en contra de que se
practique el aborto terapeútico que fue
aprobado durante el gobierno de michelle
bachelet y que permite el aborto en tres
causales violación riesgo de vida de la
madre ingreso de la vida del feto son
temas muy sensibles con candidatos en el
extremo completamente opuestos en cuanto
a estos dos temas también casi eso es
contrario al matrimonio entre dos
hombres o dos mujeres entre personas del
mismo sexo así que esto tendrá sin duda
una influencia en la próxima elección
presidencial en un momento en el que
también vimos hoy como diputado electo
por el partido de cas ponía en duda por
ejemplo el voto femenino algo que se
hizo viral y que ya ha generado el
rechazo y el desmarque por parte de cas
de esta posición estamos en un momento
en que ambos candidatos tratan de
moderar sus discursos para así también
captar a votantes del centro pero sin
duda dos temas muy importantes los que
se discuten en el con la cámara de
diputados hoy en chile